Congrats on 10 years thanks Freddy
that's awesome
I know you're like very open and talking
about are you incorporating understand
up do you feel like a lot of people like
reach out to you for advice their own
stories things like that like you know I
have a whole mechanism in place for to
respond not directly but through someone
else and with stuff that's not like that
I wouldn't want to share it publicly
okay yeah yeah so I'm welcome I mean
it's just how it works sobriety is like
you know you want to help people
yeah and it's weird they achieve and see
now like I've watched like a beer to be
flooded with it and not be able to
handle it but it's cool yeah I love it
I'm very active in the world of sobriety
I'm in my 40s now which for Steve I was
kind of like you know extra sad and
depressing as I approached 40 hmm it
really struck me that to be happy to be
to have like a good life that I need to
learn how to have a healthy relationship
right and I was doing my stand-up comedy
tour and after every show of the full
meet-and-greet and that like would look
a lot like an audition hey you know each
night and and all of this like acting
out it was such promise myself I'm gonna
learn how to be in a healthy
relationship what's not gonna hook up
but you meat stew you like Peter to you
but after my shows I do meeting groups
and people would act like it was an
audition I would act like it was an
audition to see who the lucky lady
watching and I promised myself that I
would discontinue this behavior but I
wasn't able to and so I really like a
dove into therapy and really took it
seriously and I put in a lot of work to
you know to kind of get to where I'm at
now where I have a healthy relationship
and and I'm engaged to a wonderful woman
yeah and it took a lot of work to become
the man that that this woman deserves
and so when I hear about people saying
that there's a stigma to drug and
alcohol addiction for me having done the
work of you know
the relationship sex stuff that's where
the stigma is at you know yeah I think
it's silly that that's the case because
you know in our culture even like for
guys marriage it's like oh yeah look at
that you know I did this that like like
infidelity is is rampant you know I
think that that I don't know I just have
a big proponent of doing the work and
yes I try to be a good guy
no they thanked you for sure
[Music]